typhoon ride packed winds of more than
200 kilometers an hour and made landfall
nine times last week from the east to
the far west of the philippines central
and southern islands millions of people
are having to pick up whatever is left
of their lives the devastation is
unprecedented
state weather forecasters had predicted
a powerful typhoon but when it hit the
country it exceeded their expectations
it actually um entered the period
actually of uh
so uh sort of arrested development where
there's really much much not much going
on in the storm based on uh satellite
observations
and then it is
after that was is the interesting part
after the arrested development period it
suddenly uh ramped up its development
and then that's the time that where it
reach its uh
intensity typhoon rai also hit about a
third of the country that has
historically been spared the fiercest
storms it also sustained its strength
throughout
the pattern that has emerged from this
particular typhoon is that the damage
can be
relatively far from the eye or the
center of the storm usually when a storm
barrels through our country we know
which provinces and which cities are
gonna get hit rai is not the first super
cyclone to devastate the philippines in
2013 super typhoon haiyan left a trail
of destruction and killed at least six
thousand people
it was one of the strongest typhoons
ever recorded
many scientists and environmentalists
say such extreme weather in the
philippines is the consequence of
climate change
and they're afraid it's only going to
get worse
below al jazeera manila